I'm going to start with this cuz it
seems like a crazy number 25 million
Instagram followers is there pressure in
that do you feel like you have to post
at that point yeah I definitely do feel
that but I I also give myself the
Liberty to just like not care that much
good I feel like I'm constantly like I
probably shouldn't say this it's like a
whole separate job I'm like I like
continuously lose followers every time I
post so I feel like I'm like all right
bye I guess so I'm like maybe it's
better if I just don't remind them that
they're following me and then under the
radar yeah you're you're turning 30 soon
are you excited about this I really
excited to turn 30 yeah I'm like 30s are
fun that's what I hear I just feel like
your 30s especially as a woman it's like
really when you come into yourself and
you like stop caring about what other
people think yeah I feel like that's
already coming for me and you know with
Riverdale ending after seven years I'm
like this feels like a really great time
to be turning 30 it's like a new chapter
I'm excited for you I love my 30s that's
fun how do you celebrate you go big or
do you chill um I like to have I'm very
social I like to have like everyone
gather for my birthday um I really want
to have a bounce house birthday for my
30s I love
you I love I want to just like get a big
bounce house and invite everyone and
have like you know a themed like a kids
themed birthday maybe like you know yeah
some Disney character is like my cake or
have a petting
zoo exact I will tell you during like it
saved us I ordered on thank you Amazon I
ordered a bounce house cuz my my kids
were going nuts and like we were just
doing homeschooling and all that stuff
with Co Bounce House saved us so I
applaud a bounce house M you just on the
bounce house every day yeah go get that
energy out it for you get out of the
house yeah well the new movie It's
called upgraded you seem very cute and
very sarcastic and funny in it do you
like this is it a romcom I'm it's a
romcom yeah I love that they don't make
those enough anymore now yeah I feel
like there's there's a new wave of
romcoms coming that I'm excited very for
this movement yeah do you like did you
like doing the film did you know right
off the bat you were going to be excited
about the script yeah I mean it's like
it's it I don't want to say it's devil
Wars PR esque because I feel like then
people have those expectations and
that's an iconic movie yeah but it does
feel like a version of it that exists in
the art world and I think that really
appealed to me you know playing an upand
cominging assistant there's Marissa to
shaving your legs I love which was her
choice by the way she just decided that
and I was like that's brilliant oh my
God so who is your character who do you
play I play um Anna Santos who's an
intern for an art auctioning house in
New York called irwins um and she gets
invited to go to London with her boss to
be her assistant and she meets will on
the plane who we just saw in the clip um
and he mistakes her and thinks that
she's claiming to be her boss um and she
just kind of goes along with the LIE
yeah are you good at lying are you one
of those people that's good well you're
an actor so I'm yeah but funny enough I
think actors are worse at lying
sometimes or that's what you tell us CU
acting acting is living truthfully you
know totally under imaginary
circumstances yeah I just don't know how
to lie well I start sweating yeah Even
If I Stay s in my friend I'll be like
you know what that wasn't true and I'll
out myself I feel the need to correct
myself about things I really don't need
to correct myself to the very tea you
know I'm just kidding I didn't have an
omelette for breakfast I had a burrito
I'm so sorry yeah I was going to get the
omelet and then I decided so that's I
said omelet yeah that's totally you're
just like vomiting details no one cares
about no one cares about y that is me as
we're very similar that oh my God what's
like a what's a project that you would
love to do like what's something in the
in the acting world that you would love
to do I would love have you seen poor
things no what's that I would love to
work with yoro Lanos like he is a
brilliant director like it's a
masterpiece I would love to be in like a
really absurd surreal movie like that oh
thank you for the tip too I'm to watch
it I'm a stone she's amazing oh I love
her oh I know what you're talking about
I haven't seen it yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah okay that's awesome project it put
it out there all right your
ghost listen let's do another short
commercial break everybody you can see
Camila in upgraded starting tomorrow on
Prime video she's also in the Prime
video movie mus which premieres April
[Music]
[Applause]
4th thank you guys y have a great night
I'm going
home